[Music]
[Applause]
ross tucker host of the ross tucker
football podcast works for cbs westwood
one he'll be on the sidelines for the
afc championship game in kansas city
sunday between the bengals and the chief
for westwood one tony basselli and iron
eagle did you wear a jock strap when you
played football
never
never not once i've never worn a jock
strap or a cup in my entire life
uh i don't know any football players
that ever wore a cup i do remember
i think like in college i remember some
guys
wore jockstraps and that was like all
they wore underneath their game pants
and the one year
um the our our white home pants at
princeton were almost see-through
because i remember some moms were
telling their sons that they could see
their bare butts out on the field and so
that maybe they would want to wear like
spandex shorts i gotta tell you guys i
gotta tell you guys the story right now
i don't know how you got on the jock
strap conversation
uh this morning but i swear as god is my
witness
yesterday i pick up my girls from school
i'm driving to dance class and i do a
radio hit somewhere i don't know who i
was talking to
but i said on it something about so and
so couldn't hold his you know what okay
radio interview's over
we're we're walking in in the dance
class and my one daughter my daughters
are eight nine my one daughter says
what so you a you-know-what what what
was the you-know-what that they couldn't
hold and i was like uh
like a jock strap like a jock
and they said what what's a jock strap
and i said well it's a thing that
like holds up uh uh
a boy's private so they don't flop
around
and they both looked at me
like their eyes got real big
i can't believe
you guys either bugged my car how are
you talk how are you having the same
conversation that i had with my
daughters like 10 hours ago it's a
teaching moment for you i love that
because in a million years you never
think you know when you say to your wife
oh did you talk to the girl would you
talk about
uh something that holds on to your
something your privates
and then your wife or your daughters go
home and say hey dad brought up this
thing that you put your thing in so it
doesn't jiggle around mom
yeah how do and how do i explain that
one and you know they're in the back
seat in their car seats and i'm i'm
talking about something football oh man
they couldn't hold his you-know-what i'd
even say jock but when you say you know
what your kids want to know what is you
know what
and so i was like jack jack
i had to go through the whole it was it
was
hilarious and eye-opening and so they
haven't referenced it yet i don't think
they told my wife it's good that
nobody's listening or watching
our buddy uh host a bunch of podcasts
including the ross tucker football
podcast and you can check him out on
social media at ross tucker nfl ben
roethlisberger announces the obvious
that he's going to step down
ben roethlisberger's legacy
is going to be what
i think he's a hall of famer i think
he's a first ballot hall of famer you
know what i think about when i think of
him dan i think of a couple things and i
know people
want to dive into the off the field
stuff i'm not really going to go there
that was a long time ago we talked about
it quite a bit for some people by the
way that is part of his legacy that is
something that they bring up and look i
see it all time i mean that is something
that people will bring up and i know he
has to live with that i feel like
the thing that jumps out to me is just
how much he's matured
on and off the field
during his career i mean dan when he was
first there and i know you know this
because you talk to enough people but
i'm gonna say it he was the last guy to
get there and the first guy to leave
that's what i was told
and
some of the years i was told that his
weight would get up there during the
season
to 260 270
275
and i remember distinctly thinking
there's no way this guy plays more than
like 10 years
what a terrible combination
of not watching what you eat and your
weight going ballooning up and you don't
put the time in
to really be able to
excel with the mental aspect of the game
he got by
playing street ball early in his career
you know i always said that if i was
ever going to play in my backyard or
like at recess
roethlisberger would have been my guy
he had the most uncanny ability to shrug
guys off
fend them off i mean they invented a new
way to tackle quarterbacks because of
him you couldn't tackle him low you
couldn't tackle him high he would still
throw the ball you had to tackle his
right wrist you had to tackle the ball
because he was that big that strong so
to me
his ability
to mature
with how he lived his life off the field
and mature as a football player
lose weight
put the mental aspect of the game get
rid of the ball faster he really
transitioned during his career
steelers more likely to
trade
sign a free agent or draft their next
quarterback
or stay with what they have
yeah i think what they have is i think
they've done a nice job there actually
of having a baseline
of mason rudolph and haskins competing i
don't think anybody has delusions of
grandeur for either one of those guys
but it's not a terrible
fallback plan i think somewhat curious
they might be
about what mason rudolph could do i
don't know that i envision them drafting
one where they're drafting unless they
love somebody which could be possible
maybe kenny pickett falls to them and
they love him because he's right there
in pittsburgh
i think
trade is probably more likely that's
sort of been
the steeler way
i know their fans are convinced that
they're that these
one of these veteran guys wants to come
there i'm not so sure that's the case
i'm not so sure
following ben in pittsburgh
is as enticing to an aaron rodgers or
russell wilson as steelers fans might
think it is
the news broke this morning tom pelicero
of the nfl network said the broncos were
going to hire the packers offensive
coordinator nathaniel hackett
that would lead you to believe what ross
tucker
it's hard for me to imagine dan that
aaron rodgers is a zero percent factor
in that decision
i don't think he's a huge factor because
there's so many different things in play
with his contractual status the packers
trading him all those things
but there had been rumors that he wanted
to go to denver last year i think there
were rumors on draft day that he was
close to being traded
to denver you'd have to think the
packers would prefer to trade him to the
afc
if that's what he wants to do i don't
think he wants to be there i think i
told you last week that if he lost
i thought he would be as good as gone
i'm going to stick with that i don't
think he's gonna be back
in green bay and i think denver's a good
possibility
and i think if the packers are gonna
give
aaron rodgers a decent amount of say in
this
man he kind of already wanted to go
there and now they get the offensive
coordinator that he really really likes
you know i i would say that they're
certainly dan feathering the nest
for for aaron rodgers for sure in denver
is that the first feathering the nest
reference we've had paulie this year
i think since we've been doing this i
think that's the first feathering the
nest checking okay thank you what does
it even mean by the way i never even
heard that until we had kids
and feathering the nest is like that's
like when my wife got the cribs ready
and like the uh
the nursery or whatever like getting
ready for the that's what it means right
i think so
feathering yes
that's what the broncos are doing
they're feathering the nest for baby
aaron yes paulie i see that a definition
feathering the nest you mean someone is
getting a lot of money out of something
so they could lead a comfortable life
oh mary is much more interested in doing
things for other people than feathering
her own nest
oh that means we're
taking care of what you do or what your
your house
and aaron rodgers that's i've never
heard it referenced that way
it could be multiple definite you're the
princeton guy yeah you're the ivy league
guy
so what i i say that i agree i agree
i agree
you ivy leaguers book smart so what
are you street smart that's what i want
you want to hear something dan this is
the truth too okay
there is not there's there's a
correlation
but
there are plenty of ivy league guys and
i know because i've had coaches tell me
that their football intelligence
was not where it needed to be
and it's part of the reason why they got
cut i know two guys for sure because i
talked to coaches afterwards they said
he just couldn't pick things up from a
football standpoint
meanwhile there are guys that
are probably
not real good in school not real book
smart
unbelievable
football intelligence and iq
unbelievable off the charts i think
there's some correlation but i don't
think it's as heavily correlated as
people otherwise might think
you got the kansas city chiefs and the
cincinnati bengals bengals have beaten
the chiefs during the regular season a
couple of weeks ago in cincinnati how
does cincinnati beat kansas city
i think it's tough i really think it's
tough um you know probably similar to
what they did the last time they need
jamar chase to just go bananas and have
over 200 yards receiving
two long touchdowns i think the chiefs
will have a different defensive strategy
this time dan you know last time they
played a lot of man-to-man
uh with a single high safety and when
you do that
that single high safety is in the middle
of the field he can't get to the
sideline he can't get outside the
numbers and joe burrow i was talking
with greg cosell about this on the ross
tucker podcast this morning if it's
one-on-one dan
joe burrow just throws it he trusts his
guys chase and higgins he throws up to
those guys gives them a chance to make a
play and they do
i think that the chiefs will have more
two deep safety coverages
to not allow
chase and higgins to beat them deep down
the sideline and make the bengals have
to move the ball a little bit more and
why wouldn't you i mean the offensive
line can't hold up the one big knock i
have on joe right now
he takes sacks you just can't take yeah
i mean you he like that's something
he'll improve on for next year
but
they're dead if he takes those stacks
and it's frank clark melvin ingram chris
jones against the bengals o-line you
know how i am dan i'm i'm on this i'm
praying for a close game i hope it's an
epic awesome back and forth i'm a little
bit worried
that this game could get away from the
bengals you know mahomes is not throwing
three picks like tannehill did that's
just not happening he just doesn't do it
and i don't think that the bengals are
going to be able to light up the chiefs
i think the chiefs have a better
defensive plan
i know it feels like 30 to 20 maybe the
chiefs the chiefs win by double digits i
hope it's closer than that but
i'm a little bit worried that this is
kind of the end of the line for the
bengals and in the second half they
start to
you know feel good about what they've
accomplished this year and how far
they've come
who has changed the conversation about
their careers more odell beckham or
matthew stafford
oh matthew stafford
matthew stafford i think odell beckham
is helping it
but he wasn't a gigantic factor in that
last game i mean for matthew stafford
to win two playoff games to win on the
road against tom brady and to make
the incredibly clutch throws especially
the last one that he made
after all the momentum had been lost i
mean dan i said this during the game
certain things only happen to the team
playing against tom brady in the
playoffs i don't know if he did a deal
with the devil or he has a voodoo witch
four fumbles i mean the ball gets
snapped and stafford's not ready for it
cam akers fumbles with a minute and a
half left your kicker's short on a 47
yard field goal in the nfl i don't think
i've ever even seen that i mean things
happen in that game i couldn't believe
for the rams to get give up a 27-3 lead
and stafford still
right the ship
and make that throw while adamic and sue
was about to kill him it's incredible
stafford has changed a lot of opinions
he's made the rams right for bringing
him in and i think he's got a great
chance to go to the super bowl if they
can beat the niners obviously it's tough
for the niners to win seven straight
they've won six in a row i like the rams
in that game although it'll be a great
close one stafford's changed the opinion
of him you know who else has changed
their opinion i think a little bit josh
allen i think there were some people
that were still a little skeptical of
josh allen with what he did in those two
playoff games now people are calling him
the 1b to patrick mahomes 1a
have a great weekend great to talk to
you again we'll talk to you next week
always thanks guys that's ross tucker
never word jockstrap host of the ross
tucker football podcast he'll be on the
sidelines
working the afc title game